[Musique]
en australie une invasion de souris
contraint les autorités à évacuer 420
détenus et 200 membres du personnel du
centre correctionnel de wellington en
nouvelle galles du sud
des souris à l'origine d'importants
dégâts dans le pays depuis près d'un an
les agriculteurs constatent que leur
niveau de reproduction est
inhabituellement élevé cette année les
souris se glisse partout
regardez elle tombe carrément du ciel
dans cette dans cette ferme parce que
cet agriculteur en a retrouvé d'anciens
fours euse les souris sont arrivés donc
je vous le disais à l'automne dernier
avec une récolte exceptionnelle après la
pire sécheresse jamais enregistrée
ce genre de phénomène se produit en
moyenne tous les dix ans mais les
spécialistes préviennent ça pourrait
arriver de plus en plus souvent à cause
du réchauffement climatique le
réchauffement climatique justement en
cause dans la détérioration de la grande
barrière de corail et ça inquiète
l'unesco qui souhaite l'inscrire sur la
liste des sites du patrimoine mondial en
danger
une démarche mal accueillie par
l'australie les autorités y voient un
désaveu dollar action en faveur de la
protection de l'ensemble coralliens qui
est par ailleurs un atout touristique
majeur pour le pays
la grande barrière de corail s'étend sur
2300 km de long or la moitié des corps
ont disparu depuis 1995 dès que je suis
arrivé j'ai senti cette odeur en fait et
voilà danser
pas une grande cuisine et avec rob
nabeul sauf qu'elle est en paix de sa
poubelle dans la verse et rôle à ce
matin donc libération explique que
europe deviendra radio fn puisque ces
news l'est déjà
ces attaques contre notre chaîne ses
incarnations illustre la place que ces
news a pris dans le pass une parole
libre un ton nouveau des personnalités
différentes clivante diverses qui
nourrissent le débat contradictoire loin
du politiquement correct de l'esprit de
chapelle ou du prêt-à-penser étape quand
vous n'avez pas pensé plus tôt
ça vient tard c'est la politique la
politique la politique c'est fini la
politique pour moi mais ça je sais
n'était pas question de d'anticiper de
commencer c'est un métier les
spectateurs à voile a way est donc de
plus en plus d'ailleurs
il faut regarder les gens dans les yeux
il faut avant les ges bonjour monsieur
bonjour madame
j'ai un coeur et je trouve toujours son
corps de s'arroger le monopole du coeur
n'avait pas je vais être très doué mais
je comprends pas que vous n'ayez pas
fait sept quartiers ses coups de pied
dad
et ça c'est intéressant comme à
décrypter le personnage à nicolas
sarkozy il a à la fois cette espèce de
verticalité quand il parle il assoit les
choses et vous regarde
et puis à cette toute petite voix car il
va se faire plaindre je suis comme vous
je suis comme vous vous mais je suis
président je suis comme des faux salon
de l'agriculture y avait monsieur
hollande toujours là j'étais présent
l'abri oui ils passaient dans l'allée et
puis j'ai interpol il mesure landes
monsieur hollande
je vous pose une question maintenant est
ce que vous pouvez revaloriser les
retraites qu'elles sont toutes petites
retraites
oui c'est celle là qui m'a répondu
attendez madame vous donner le bon goût
de la carotte lui même prédit quelques
carottes
trop que héloïse et n'a qu'à en un an de
relation ils s'embrouillent vraiment
beaucoup beaucoup pour un oui pour un
non
la relation n'est pas stable du tout est
à vraiment en crise tant que genre en
une photo peuvent retirer ces vidéos qui
ont été postées ces derniers jours sur
le sur les réseaux sociaux
vous allez voir se font piquer ensuite
voilà ils agitent frénétiquement le bras
voilà comme ça alors ça ressemble un peu
à une danse alors selon ces ados sur les
réseaux ce geste aurait donc deux effet
le premier éviter les courbatures et le
deuxième faire diffuser davantage le
vaccin l'ombre aux as et surtout en
angleterre mais ces vidéos apparaître ça
a l'air un peu idiot 1 je sais pas en
quoi vous savez quoi ma saleh et ben oui
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ma voisine l'a 20 ans de moins que nous
donc devant chez elle comme sa porte sur
le palier parce que des fois on
entendait du bruit donc ça nous a tous
compris
donc oui un dimanche à 6 heures du soir
après enfin marcher sur la ville de
romans oui à mes genre en vengeance un
peu pour l'envié peut pour la vengeance
vous pour montrer qu'on n'était pas tous
lieux
voilà donc c'est juste comme ça ok
la vie jour après jour nuit après nuit à
quoi ça sert détruire la terre
roméo mémoire car comme on me fait que
travailler quoi qu'est ce tu mon boulot
ça ça me fait vraiment chier
moi je préférais même qu'il est mais
grâce à la limite comme moi ici comme là
c'est franchement comme gérer avec bette
fort et ça fait du bien en fait il ya un
nouveau public est alors un pas
intéressant
le monde ne le sait pas encore tout le
monde le sait pas voilà c'est l'occasion
et le papa eto'o courtois nom alors je
parle alors justement c'est bien en même
temps c'est ça laissera des traces un
rudy tu pourras pas oublier que tu l'as
pris à la télé c'est un maudit naissant
les fils un gros vide ça change
oui ça change beaucoup et puis une
bourriche voilà on profite de ce moment
là on poursuite du silence r je t'écoute
ça c'est du bon sens ça change la les
studios disney qui ont décidé d'apporter
plus de couleurs cette fois alors
princesse la plus célèbre alors à l'oral
et lèvres rouge comme la rose des
cheveux noirs comme l'ébène en revanche
sa peau ne sera pas aussi blanche car la
prochaine blanche-neige et métis à c
m
aujourd'hui elle voit une question
demeure toutefois à propos du prochain
blanche-neige comment gérer la polémique
autour de la scène finale le fameux
baiser du prince charmant ce baiser
considéré comme un baiser non consentie
par les militants de la culture de
l'annulation en anglais la can se
côtoient bon on est chez les fous quand
même c'est les mains fait les fous
certaines couvertures